un coup de booster c'est ainsi que jean
michel coignard directeur académique des
yvelines a qualifié hier lors d'une
conférence de presse les visites
successives dans le département ces
dernières semaines du ministre de
l'éducation nationale vincent peillon et
du président de la république françois
hollande
le directeur académique se dit plutôt
satisfait de cette rentrée même s'il
n'oublie pas l'incident d'achères la
séquestration d'une inspectrice dans une
école maternelle par des parents qui
souhaitait l'ouverture d'une nouvelle
classe ce que j'en tire pour les
responsabilités après la rentrée c'est
que si ça ne relève pas d'une ouverture
de classe comme on en fait aujourd'hui
février revanche effectivement j'en vois
un enseignant supplémentaire à charge
pour l'école d'organiser son activité
les prises en charge plus agile avec cet
enseignant de plus pas d'ouvertures de
classes officielle pour l'école
maternelle vola d'achères dans le reste
du département quatre classes ont fermé
comme à l'école élémentaire claude monet
d'elancourt
en revanche 22 classes ont été ouvertes
dans des écoles maternelles et
élémentaires à versailles bois d'arcy ou
encore magny les hameaux
selon les syndicats enseignants snes
csnu et pépé les ouvertures de classes
ne compense pas les fermetures de ces
cinq dernières années dans le
département
côté recrutement 22 nouveaux enseignants
ont été accueillis dans les yvelines
avec une problématique non résolues pour
l'instant comment garder les professeurs
sur le territoire à long terme comme
nous avons beaucoup donné aux entrants
et je m'aperçois que pour le premier
degré y compris dans les yvelines
ces nouveaux entrants sont souvent venus
d'ailleurs sont venus de province ont
fait leurs études à paris et donc une
partie d'entre eux ne va pas se fixer
définitivement dans notre région se soit
particulièrement dans les yvelines
résoudre département c'est bien que
structurellement il faut qu on
s'accoutume au fait qu'on a un manque ou
un besoin permanent de nouveaux
personnels la solution réside peut-être
dans le développement de nouveaux
masters enseignement dans les facs du
territoire de l'académie de versailles
un projet de loi en ce sens devrait être
présenté d'ici la fin de l'année
enfin changement notable fini
l'inspection académique au chesnay
les 200 employés du site déménageront à
la toussaint dans de nouveaux locaux
avenue du centre à guyancourt
ils seront sur le même site qu'une
partie des services du rectorat